وبجانب الاحتجاجات هناك سلاح اخر بيد
الرافدين هو الاضرابات اعلن الاتحاد العام
لنقابه العمال الاسرائيليه تنظيم اضراب
عام للضغط طبعا على الحكومه حتى تتراجع قد
يشل قرار الاتحاد الذي يمثله اكثر من 700
الف عامل العديد من القطاعات نتحدث عن
البنوك عن النقل الى العاملين الصحيين
وايضا اجزاء كبيره من الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
بالفعل اعلنت النقابات الطبيه عن اضراب
شامل في القطاع الصحي وبالتزامن اعلنت
لجنه العمال في مطار برج غوريون الدولي عن
ايقاف حركه الملاحه الجويه بالمطار طبعا
تضامنا مع الرافدين للتعديلات التعديلات
القضائيه اثارت غضبا عاربا ايضا في مجالس
طلاب الجامعات وايضا المدارس ولكن رغم كل
هذا الاعتراض من قطاعات عده ما زال
نتنياهو باقي على جوهر التعديلات القضائيه
قال ان حكومته تواجه حمله دعائيه سلبيه
وضخمه